for over 50 years now Moore's law has
served for me and millions of others as
an inspiring beacon of what kind of
amazing future brilliant engineers can
build no I'm just making your kids laugh
all of today it was great so first in
your eyes what is Moore's law if you
could define for people who don't know
well the simple statement was from
Gordon Moore was double the number of
transistors every two years something
like that and then my operational model
is we increase the performance of
computers by 2x every 2 or 3 years and
it's wiggled around substantially over
time and also in how we deliver
performance has changed the foundational
idea was to X 2 transistors every 2
years the current cadence is something
like they call it a shrink factor like
point six every two years which is not
0.5 but that that's referring strictly
again to the original definition of
transistor count a shrink factor just
getting them smaller small as well well
as you use for a constant chip area if
you make the transistor smaller by 0.6
then you get 1 over 0.6 more transistors
so can you linger on it a little longer
what's what's a broader what do you
think should be the broader definition
of Moore's law when you mentioned before
how you think of performance just
broadly what's a good way to think about
Moore's law well first of all so I I've
been aware of Moore's law for 30 years
in which sense well I've been designing
computers for 40 you just watching it
before your eyes kind of well and
somewhere where I became aware of it I
was also informed that Moore's law was
gonna die in 10 to 15 years and so I
thought that was true at first but then
after 10 years it was gonna die in 10 to
15 years and then at one point it was
gonna die in five years and then it went
back up to ten years and at some point I
decided not to worry about that
particular product on occasion for the
rest of my life which is which is fun
and then
I joined Intel and everybody said
Moore's law is dead and I thought that's
sad because it's the Moore's law company
and it's not dead and it's always been
gonna die and you know humans you like
these apocryphal kind of statements like
we'll run out of food or a run out of
air or an out of room or run out of you
know something right but it's still
incredible this lived for as long as it
has and yes there's many people who
believe now that Moore's law is dead
you know makin join the last 50 years of
people who had the thing yeah there's a
long tradition but why do you think if
you can in touch try to understand it
why do you think it's not dead
well fern Hartley let's just think
people think Moore's law is one thing
transistors get smaller but actually
under the sheets there's literally
thousands of innovations and almost all
those innovations have their own
diminishing return curves so if you
graph it it looks like a cascade of
diminishing return curves I don't know
what to call that
but the result is an exponential curve
at least it has been so and we keep
inventing new things so if you're an
expert in one of the things on a
diminishing return curve right and you
can see it's Plateau you will probably
tell people while this is this is done
meanwhile some other pile of people are
doing something different so that's
that's just normal so then there's the
observation of how small could a
switching device be so a modern
transistor is something like a thousand
by a thousand by thousand atoms right
and you get quantum effects down around
two to two to ten atoms so you can
imagine a transistor as small as 10 by
10 by 10 so that's a million times
smaller and then the quantum
computational people are working away at
how to use quantum effects so a thousand
by thousand five thousand atoms it's a
really clean way of putting it well fin
like a modern transistor if you look at
the fan it's like a hundred and twenty
items wide but we can make that thinner
and
there's there's a gate wrapped around at
an inner space II mean there's a whole
bunch of geometry and you know a
competent transistor designer could
count both atoms in every single
direction like there's techniques now to
already put down atoms in a single
atomic layer and you can place atoms if
you want to it's just you know from a
manufacturing process if placing an atom
takes ten minutes and you need to put
you know 10 to the 23rd atoms together
to make a computer it would take a long
time so the the methods are you know
both shrinking things and then coming up
with effective ways to control what's
happening manufacture stabling cheaply
yeah so so the innovation stock is
pretty broad you know there's yours
equipment there's optics there's
chemistry there's physics there's
material science there's metallurgy
there's lots of ideas about when you put
different materials together how they
interact are they stable is very stable
over temperature you know like are they
repeatable you know there's look there's
like literally thousands of technologies
involved but just for the shrinking you
don't think we're quite yet close to the
fundamental limits in physics I did a
talk on Moore's Law and I asked for a
road map to a path of 100 and after two
weeks they said we only got to fifty a
hundred what's a 100 extra 100 a shrink
we only got 250 and I said once you go
to another two weeks well here's the
thing about Moore's law right so I
believe that the next 10 or 20 years of
shrinking is going to happen right now
as a computer designer there's you have
two stances you think it's going to
shrink in which case you're designing
and thinking about architecture in a way
that you'll use more transistors or
conversely not be swamped by the
complexity of all the transistors you
get right you have to have a strategy
you know so you're open to the
possibility and waiting for the
possibility of a whole new army of
transistors ready to work I'm expecting
affecting more transistors every two or
three years by a number large enough
that how you think about design how you
think about architecture has to change
like imagine you're you build built
brick buildings out of bricks and every
year the bricks are half the size or
every two years well if you kept
building bricks the same way you know so
many bricks per person per day the
amount of time to build a building when
we go up exponentially
right right but if you said I know
that's coming so now I'm going to design
equipment and moves bricks faster uses
them better because maybe you're getting
something out of the smaller bricks more
strengths inner walls you know less
material efficiency out of that so once
you have a roadmap with what's going to
happen
transistors they're gonna get we're
gonna get more of them then you design
all this collateral around it to take
advantage of it and also to cope with it
like that's the thing people to
understand it's like if I didn't believe
in Moore's law and Moore's law
transistors showed up my design teams
were all drowned so what's the what's
the hardest part of this in flood of new
transistors I mean even if you just look
historically throughout your career
what's what's the thing what
fundamentally changes when you add more
transistors in in the task of designing
an architecture there's there's two
constants right one of those people
don't get smarter I think by the way
there's some signs shown that we do get
smarter because nutrition or whatever
yeah sorry to bring that what effect yes
yeah nobody understands it nobody knows
if it's still going on so that's all or
whether it's real or not but yeah that's
a I sort of Amen but not if I believe
for the most part people aren't getting
much smarter the evidence doesn't
support it that's right
and then teams can't grow that much
right all right so human beings
understand you know we're really good in
teams of ten you know up two teams of a
hundred they can know each other beyond
that you have to have organizational
boundaries so you're kind of you have
those are pretty hard constraints right
so then you have to divide and conquer
like as the designs get bigger you have
to divide it into pieces
you know that the power of abstraction
layers is really high we used to build
computers out of transistors now we have
a team that turns transistors and logic
cells and our team that turns them into
functional you know it's another one it
turns in computers right so we have
abstraction layers in there and you have
to think about when do you shift gears
on that we also use faster computers to
build faster computers so some
algorithms run twice as fast on new
computers but a lot about rhythms are N
squared so you know a computer with
twice as many transistors and it might
take four Tom's times as long to run so
you have to refactor at the software
like simply using faster computers to
build bigger computers doesn't work so
so you have to think about all these
things so in terms of computing
performance and the exciting possibility
that more powerful computers bring is
shrinking the thing we've been talking
about one of the for you one of the
biggest exciting possibilities of
advancement in performance or is there
are other directions that you're
interested in like like in the direction
of sort of enforcing given parallelism
or like doing massive parallelism in
terms of many many CPUs you know
stacking CPUs on top of each other that
kind of that kind of parallelism or you
kind of well think about it a different
way so old computers you know slow
computers you said a equal B plus C
times D pretty simple right and then we
made faster computers with vector units
and you can do proper equations and
matrices right and then modern like AI
computations or like convolutional
neural networks where you convolve one
large data set against another and so
there's sort of this hierarchy of
mathematics
you know from simple equation to linear
equations to matrix equations to it's a
deeper kind of computation and the
datasets are getting so big that people
are thinking of data as a topology
problem you know data is organized in
some immense shape and then the
computation which sort of wants to be
get data from immense
and do some computation on it so the
with computers have allowed people to do
is have algorithms go much much further
so that that paper you you reference the
Sutton paper they talked about you know
like in a I started it was apply rule
sets to something that's a very simple
computational situation and then when
they did first chess thing they solved
deep searches so have a huge database of
moves and results deep search but it's
still just a search right now we we take
large numbers of images and we use it to
Train these weight sets that we convolve
across it's a completely different kind
of phenomena we call that AI now they're
doing the next generation and if you
look at it they're going up this
mathematical graph right and then the
computations the both computation and
data sets support going up that graph
yeah the kind of computation of my I
mean I would argue that all of it is
still a search right just like you said
a topology problems data sets he's
searching the data sets for valuable
data and also the actual optimization of
neural networks is a kind of search for
the I don't know if you looked at the
inner layers of finding a cat it's not a
search it's it's a set of endless
projection so you know projection and
here's a shadow of this phone yeah right
then you can have a shadow of that onto
something in a shadow on that or
something if you look in the layers
you'll see this layer actually describes
pointy ears and round eyeness and
fuzziness and but the computation to
tease out the attributes is not search
right ain't like the inference part
might be searched but the trainings not
search okay well 10m in deep networks
they look at layers and they don't even
know it's represented and yet if you
take the layers out it doesn't work okay
so if I don't think it's search all
right well but you have to talk to him a
mathematician about what that actually
is oh you would disagree but the the
it's just semantics I think it's not but
it's certainly not I would say it's
absolutely not semantics but okay all
right well if you want to go there so
optimization to me is search and we're
trying to optimize the ability of a
neural network to detect cat ears and
this difference between chess and the
space the incredibly multi-dimensional
hundred thousand dimensional space that
you know networks are trying to optimize
over is nothing like the chessboard
database so it's a totally different
kind of thing and okay in that sense you
can say yeah yeah you know I could see
how you you might say if you the funny
thing is it's the difference between
given search space and found search
space exactly yeah maybe that's the
different way that's right but okay but
you're saying what's your sense in terms
of the basic mathematical operations and
the architectures can be hard where that
enables those operations do you see the
CPUs of today still being a really core
part of executing those mathematical
operations
yes well the operations you know
continue to be add subtract loads or
compare and branch it's it's remarkable
so it's it's interesting that the
building blocks of you know computers or
transistors and you know under that
atoms so you got atoms transistors logic
gates computers right you know
functional units and computers the
building blocks of mathematics at some
level are things like adds and subtracts
and multiplies but the space mathematics
can describe is I think essentially
infinite but the computers that run the
algorithms are still doing the same
things now a given algorithm may say I
need sparse data or I need 32-bit data
or I need you know like a convolution
operation that naturally takes 8-bit
data multiplies it and sums it up a
certain way so the like the data types
in tensorflow imply an optimization set
but
you go right down and look at the
computers it's an inorganic lies like
like that hasn't changed much
now the quantum researchers think
they're going to change that radically
and then there's people who think about
analog computing because you look in the
brain and it seems to be more analog ish
you know that maybe there's a way to do
that more efficiently but we have a
million acts on computation and I don't
know the reference the relationship
between computational let's say
intensity and the ability to hit math
mathematical abstractions I don't know
anybody scribe dad but but just like you
saw an AI you went from rulesets the
simple search to complex search to say
found search like those are you know
orders of magnitude more computation to
do and as we get the next two orders of
magnitude like a friend Raja godori said
like every order of magnitude change the
computation fundamentally changes what
the computation is doing here oh you
know the expression the difference in
quantity is the difference in kind you
know the difference between ant and ant
hill right or neuron and brain you know
there's there's there's this indefinable
place where the the quantity changed the
quality right now we've seen that happen
in mathematics multiple times and you
know my my guess is it's gonna keep
happening so your senses yeah if you
focus head down and shrinking a
transistor let's not just head down and
we're aware about the software stacks
that are running in the computational
lows and we're kind of pondering what do
you do with a petabyte of memory that
wants to be accessed in a sparse way and
have you know the kind of calculations
ai programmers want so there's that
there's a dialogue interaction but when
you go in the computer chip you know you
find adders and subtractors and
multipliers and so if you zoom out then
with as you mentioned which Sutton the
idea that most of the development in the
last many decades in the AI research
came
just leveraging computation and just the
simple algorithms waiting for the
computation to improve well suffer guys
have a thing they called the the problem
of early optimization right so if you
write a big software stack and if you
start optimizing like the first thing
you write the odds of that being the
performance limiter is low but when you
get the whole thing working can you make
it to X faster by optimizing the right
things sure while you're optimizing that
could you've written a new software
stack which would have been a better
choice maybe now you have creative
tension so but the whole time as you're
doing the writing the that's the
software we're talking about the
Hardware underneath gets faster which
goes back to the Moore's law if Moore's
Law is going to continue then your AI
research should expect that to show up
and then you make a slightly different
set of choices then we've hit the wall
nothing's gonna happen and from here
it's just us rewriting algorithms like
that seems like a failed strategy for
the last 30 years of Moore's laws death
so so can you just linger on it I think
you've answered it but it just asked the
same dumb question over and over so what
why do you think Moore's Law is not
going to die which is the most promising
exciting possibility of why they won't
done that's five ten years so is it that
continues shrinking the transistor or is
it another s-curve that steps in and it
totally servo shrinking the transistor
is literally thousands of innovations
right so there's so this they're all
answers and it's there's a whole bunch
of s-curves just kind of running their
course and and being reinvented and new
things you know the the semiconductor
fabricators and technologists have all
announced what's called nanowires so
they they took a fan which had a gate
around it and turned that into little
wire so you have better control that and
they're smaller and then from there
there are some obvious steps about how
to shrink that so the metallurgy around
wire stocks and stuff has very obvious
abilities
shrink and you know there's a whole
combination of things there to do your
sense is that we're gonna get a lot yeah
this innovation from just that shrinking
yeah like a factor of a hundred flawed
yeah I would say that's incredible
and it's totally it's only ten or
fifteen years
now you're smarter you might note but to
me it's totally unpredictable of what
that hundred ex would bring in terms of
the nature of the computation that
people be yeah you familiar with Bell's
law so for a long time those mainframes
minis workstation PC mobile Moore's law
drove faster smaller computers right and
then we were thinking about Moore's law
Rogers godori said every 10 X generates
a new computation so scalar vector
matrix topological computation right and
if you go look at the industry trends
there was you know mainframes and
mini-computers and PCs and then the
internet took off and then we got mobile
devices and now we're building 5g
wireless with one millisecond latency
and people are starting to think about
the smart world where everything knows
you recognizes you like like like the
transformations are gonna be like
unpredictable how does it make you feel
that you're one of the key architects of
this kind of futures you're not we're
not talking about the architects of the
high level people who build the Angry
Bird apps and LAN Xang Angry Bird of who
knows we're gonna be that's the whole
point of the universe let's take a stand
at that and the attention distracting
nature of mobile phones I'll take a
stand but anyway in terms of it that
matters much the the side effects of
smartphones or the attention distraction
which part well who knows you know where
this is all leading it's changing so
fast
wait back my parents used to all my
sisters were hiding in the closet with a
wired phone with a dial on it stop
talking your friends all day right now
my wife feels with my kids for talking
to their friends all day on tax
looks the same to me it's always it's
echoes of the same day okay but you are
the one of the key people architecting
the hardware of this future how does
that make you feel do you feel
responsible do you feel excited so we're
we're in a social context so there's
billions of people on this planet there
are literally millions of people working
on technology I feel lucky to to be you
know what doing what I do and getting
paid for it and there's an interest in
it but there's so many things going on
in parallel it's like the actions are so
unpredictable if I wasn't here somebody
also doing the the vectors of all these
different things are happening all the
time you know there's a I'm sure some
philosopher or meta philosophers you
know wondering about how we transform
our world so you can't deny the fact
that these tools whether that these
tools are changing our world that's
right
do you think it's changing for the
better
so somebody's I read this thing recently
it said the people the two disciplines
with the highest GRE scores in college
our physics in philosophy right and
they're both sort of trying to answer
the question why is there anything right
and the philosophers you know are on the
kind of theological side and the
physicists are obviously on the you know
the material side and there's a hundred
billion galaxies with a hundred billion
stars it seems well repetitive at best
so I you know there's on our way to 10
billion people I mean it's hard to say
what it's all for if that's what you're
asking
yeah I guess I guess they do tend to are
significantly increases in complexity
and I'm curious about how computations
like like our world our physical world
inherently generates mathematics it's
kind of obvious right so we have X Y Z
coordinates you take a sphere you make
it bigger you get a surface that falls
you know grows by r-square
like it generally generates mathematics
and the mathematicians and the
physicists have been having a lot of fun
talking to each other for years and
computation has been let's say
relatively pedestrian like computation
in terms of mathematics has been doing
binary binary algebra while those guys
have been gallivanting through the
nether realms of possibility right now
recently the computation lets you do
math McMath ematic allah computations
that are sophisticated enough that
nobody understands how the answers came
out right machine learning machine lying
yeah it used to be you get data set you
guess at a function the function is
considered physics if it's predictive of
new functions new data sets modern you
can take a large data set with no
intuition about what it is and use
machine learning to find a pattern that
has no function right and it can arrive
at results that I don't know if they're
completely mathematically describable so
a computation is kind of done something
interesting compared to a legal B plus C
you